we wanted the equation of the circle we
wanted to translate all of the all of
the picture into X's and Y's and that
kind of thing cuz they're quite we're
quite good we're developing the skill
with X's and Y's right we use this do
you remember we use this guy this is the
distance formula and underneath the big
square root we've got this stuff do you
remember what the stuff was X 1 X 1
minus X 2 plus y 1 minus y 2 by they
just the chip next year when you get
into year 11 and 12 we give you this
thing called the reference sheet it
takes formulas like this and because we
want you to understand mathematics is
not primarily about memorizing things
and we just give you these formulas so
that if you can't if you have trouble
remembering it when you go you don't
need to have trouble remembering however
at the moment you don't have that and
it's worth learning this is not hard to
learn where this comes from is
Pythagoras remember pythagoras
pythagoras looks like this see how
pythagoras is something squared plus
something squared did that see that
right hand side that's this there's the
something squared plus something squared
does that make sense so this comes from
Pythagoras that's how I remember that
that's a plus and these guys a minus
fone okay now what does off a lot of
this sorry what does this distance
formula look like for this circle I'm
going to compare these two points here's
my sin times that I've just drawn in
just by eye that's sort of what it looks
like and I've called this point over
here X comma Y that's a bit weird you
called it like we didn't put numbers now
we put letters why do we do that okay
very good
we don't know their value they could be
anywhere on the circle they vary so
that's why they're variables okay so
let's go ahead and see what happens when
we crunch through this formula for these
points okay
when we have a look at the x-coordinates
if we make this the first point and this
the second point I'm going to have X
take away what negative two so there's a
there's a double negative there which
means that it's X plus two that okay
when I have a look at the y-coordinates
yeah look Y minus 4
now there was a piece of efficient I
didn't supply so I'm just going to sort
of roughly estimate it which is a radius
okay now just I mean I'm just making
this up so you tell me if this is x
equals negative 2 what would you
estimate this distance looks like this
is what you're asking I think it looks
sort of like 3 X looks sorta like 3 so
I'm going to say let's make that radius
3 unfortunately what that does mean is
my diagram is totally stuffed because
this guy over here can't actually touch
can you tell me why can you tell me why
think about it if the radius is 3 like
you're telling me yeah that means the
radius is the same everywhere isn't it
so look at this guy see that that's also
3 but look I said it was up at 4
yeah it's because my circle is like a
bit of an egg but anyway you get the
idea so therefore I'm going to have to
be more like this sorry about that but
you get the idea so why am i down here
it's because if this is 3 it can't reach
to the axis because you're 4 units all
that all right I'll need you have a
question or suggestion yeah
we can come up with different numbers
for this and that's all fine okay
well I'm going to simplify it in this
way remember I didn't want to write the
square root do you remember that so what
did I did at both sides to get rid of it
I square J cube question so we'll
actually provide you something I'm only
estimating because I just made up this
question so sorry I'll wear that so this
is what we've got now I can expand this
thing on the right hand side there's no
reason to because if I covered all of
this up and all I provided to you was
this this is actually in exactly the
form that I want because I can read
everything I need off of this equation
can you tell me I mean you can see it on
the picture but how can I work out from
here what the radius is which number do
I look at I look at the nine but the
radius is not known the radius is the
square root of this this is three
squared so three is the radius I can
also find out the center from here you
can see what the center is that where do
I get that from it's um it's the
opposites of these numbers you see that
see that that's a plus two so the x
coordinate will be was is negative two
like we drew it and then here you've got
minus four
so the the y coordinate will be just for
you see that so now it could give you
some other random equation how about
this how about 121 equals this how about
this guy what's the radius
the radius is 11 because this is 11
squared just like this is 3 squared ok
have a look down here yep
what's the sensor going to be well the
x-coordinate will be 7
what will the like wouldn't be this is
the first one we started with remember
it start at the center this is in fact y
minus 0 squared but that's why we don't
write it does that make sense so now
whatever equation you've got you can
find out all the important things about
it ok